he performed obviously in the UK you
know and you performed in the United
States what's the difference what would
you say is the main difference between
comedy audiences here versus in the
United Kingdom well here people are you
know the kind of upfront everybody comes
and says you know we'll a lot so it's
kind of very welcoming but you also feel
like you better not screw up whereas
back in Britain and not so much in
island but certainly in Britain it's
much more of a an emotional treasure
hunt trying to locate people they sort
of they sit there with their arms folded
and you feel like you've already been in
a long-term relationship with them for
about 35 years before you say hello
before you hit the stage you come out
and their arms are already crossed yeah
like you come out you say hey is
everybody well it's a genuine question
and not like here wherever people are
just saying hello you do it in Britain
say okay do you need me to get anything
any medication so we can detect do you
find Americans to be less reserved then
and people and say yeah they are and I
kind of like that because there's
everything's front and center it's all
out there and I you know growing up in
Ireland it's a Catholic country so
everybody wears their emotions you know
outside and you ask somebody how they
are and they drop this you know mackerel
net of feelings all over you that's how
I am see if you can stand up now
it sounds awful yeah well no it's admit
there's a kind of people have perfected
certain you know emotions in our live
like guilt is kind of bad yes yes that's
amazing yeah what can do down the phone
you people were ringing up from all over
the world to check on the relatives how
are you how are you doing in this era
it's not good well what I thought they
gave you medicine yeah I stopped taking
that well why what's what that's gonna
be agony isn't it yeah but the pain is
company so people guilt yeah my it's
funny my people
I'm a hundred percent Irish we've been
in this country like 160 years yeah but
it was a hundred percent Irish people
marrying a hundred percent Irish people
in central Massachusetts yeah which
means I'm dangerously inbred but it also
means that I have all of that pure Irish
craziness it's never been diluted with
anything else so all you're talking
about the guilt yeah a most pure emotion
constantly churning never resolved shame
blame and vengeance being the main
currencies in our thanks yeah stick
thanks so what happens is you you a you
experience shame you blame somebody else
and rather than pursue your dreams you
devote the rest of your life to
vengeance
passed down through the generations
preserved their bitterness is preserved
yeah yes and you polish it at night
right
let golem with the ring that's right you
know you're just well refined over
centuries I love it I love it you just
began a new US tour you know what love
is that you a lot of comedians talk only
about Trump now not so much you you
mentioned him a little bit tonight but
you you're you sort of go out of your
way to not talk about well sometimes I
have done because you say it to the
audience you want you we're gonna talk
about Trump and there's a kind of a
collective groan yes and they don't want
to talk about them they want to break
because you where everybody's waking up
and he's there and your face and your
bear in mind that this is a guy who if
you heard him behind you on a bus you
put your headphones in so when people
people are waking up to it every day you
know they get a bit tired there's a
fatigue yeah there's a certain kind of
fatigue and you know I love people just
don't want to hear about him they don't
want to hear about what he's saying they
won't think she should but he should
focus on things he understands like his
hair and getting that situation resolved
he must know somebody with staples
[Laughter]
you